hey guys it is the tenth of June today
my name's Jess McDonald and you're tuned
into the games but news show well I
bring you the very coolest in gaming
news of the day here's some of that if
you're getting a little sick of
Assassin's Creed then Ubisoft have just
the thing for you they're after your
personal inputs to make sure upcoming
title syndicate is a little less unity
and a little more assassins creed to
Ubisoft have launched what they're
calling a play test roadshow wherein
gamers can play Assassin's Creed
syndicate and chat directly with the
devs about their thoughts which will
supposedly have a real impact on the
final product the first stop of the tour
will be in la at e3 if you're in the
area you can apply to Ubisoft with your
details for a chance to be involved it's
worth noting that Ubisoft have added
what they're calling an experienced
players only policies although I've just
decided to reference it as no noobs no
subsequent stops for the roadshow have
been announced yet you probably remember
hearing about the sweet looking dinosaur
game coming from Studio wildcard well it
seems to be doing pretty well with over
400,000 copies sold since it's early
access release Ark survival evolved has
now made over 10 million bucks and is
probably initiated what will become a
slow of dinosaur games over the next few
years although currently unfinished the
massive sales figures probably means the
$25 early access version has seriously
charmed players co-creative director
Jessie rough sucked old games industry
international that the initial revenue
has well and truly covered the game's
1.5 million development costs for the
last seven months as for the rest of the
dev time wrap zaka said quote eighty
percent of the main game is done with
hundreds of hours of gameplay there
already it's just down to balancing and
feedback from the players if it all goes
well we may even add more content once
the community gets their hands on the
mod tools the game got a healthy leg up
thanks to some avid twitch streaming and
hype over the impending Jurassic world
film arcs
I've evolved is due out in June 2016 for
pc xbox one and ps4 a massive patch for
The Witcher 3 has arrived for Xbox one
so if you're tired of passing through
game worlds boundaries during the
through time and space quest and
becoming permanently inebriated after
being invoked during the no place like
home quest then this is your lucky day
patch notes are weird the update landed
alongside the game's latest batch of
free DLC and includes a huge list of
game fixes changes and tweaks among
those as a fix for the games XP bug
where experience wasn't awarded
correctly and a twig which increases the
size of the game's notoriously small
menu text there have also been
improvements to the game's technical
performance and the fix for the infinite
money exploit that you could previously
take advantage of by killing cows the
patch was already released last week for
pc and ps4 you can read the full very
long list of patch notes in our story on
gamespot let me know down in the
comments if you reckon dinosaur games
could be the next big thing and what you
think of them you can head to gain spot
where we've got more stories on GTA 5
players getting a whole lot more cash
and the first gameplay from ratchet and
clank for ps4 that is everything that i
want to tell you about today but do you
be sure to pop back same time tomorrow
for a bunch more news
you